[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and today i'm
being challenged to recreate these super
adorable among us sushi characters from
wave mount dora let's take a look at the
video it looks like we just need to
make two characters i'll shape the rice
with my hands oh that's the little
backpack making the orange one with
salmon that's radish okay we're gonna
cut it out with kitchen scissors this
seems fairly simple i think this is
pretty doable okay the nori sheet what
is this neon yellow paper it is green
soy paper ah that seems accessible we'll
see if i can find that okay stick it
together with nori again oh my god
the little bone oh my god so cute okay
wrap it around okay spicy tuna for the
gore the flesh upon the kill okay i
don't think this is too difficult i
should definitely not say that before
the challenge starts because you're
about to probably see me have a very
tough time it looks like i'll need sushi
rice salmon tuna radish nori sheets and
neon green soy wrappers
okay to start we're gonna cut our salmon
sashimi have i ever cut sashimi before
no but it'll all be okay i feel like i
have to be so careful oh my goodness i
feel like my fingers are too fat for
this it's like when i'm in the reactor
room doing simon says and someone
reports a body and then you have to
start all over after the discussion's
over so annoying oh
baby
look how beautiful this is ah you know
what's another annoying task when you
have fat fingers the maze and if you
make one wrong move
you have to start all over because you
can't backtrack like why
oh my gosh i'm so happy these are
looking so good i'm going to quit my job
and become a sushi chef i cut all my
salmon slices and now it's time to shape
the first character
okay i have a ball of rice here so he
shapes this pretty long and i want to
remember that i want this to stand
afterwards so it needs to be able to
hold down the weight at the bottom so
far so good gonna cut its legs oh that's
actually not bad look at that he's so
cute
i grabbed a bowl of water i think if i
mess up the water will be a good eraser
for any mistakes i'm gonna wet the knife
so the rice doesn't stick all right
first one is on
oh so cute
let's add the second one i'm gonna pick
up the prettiest one though i will say
this is not bad does this stand is the
real question
oh my gosh he's so cute
okay i'm gonna reshape him a little bit
although i will say orange is always so
sus for me in my circle of among us
friends it's always orange and red
planting something together they're both
sus and then chances are they are the
imposter now we need to cut our radish
this is going to be the little goggles
on the spacesuit i'm gonna cut out the
rough shape i want first and then just
clean up the edges i think that'll be
easier all right let's just shape this
guy this game really saved me in the
pandemic i feel like it made me make new
friends it brought me closer to my
college friends because i don't get to
see them all the time anymore and now we
just play together all the time i
literally rang in the new year playing
among us with my among us crew shout out
to them we all have our among us crew
you know who they are let's just take
this time to appreciate them okay i
think this shape is pretty good let's
put it on him give it a quick
fit
that's not bad that's not bad at all
i cannot wait to eat you i am obsessed
with you his name is
orange i'm so creative
okay now we need the nori slice so this
nori needs to be the same thickness as
my radish which is about a quarter inch
thick all right my measuring technique
is not at all precise so i'm just going
to wing it that's a good thickness
okay i think that's good time to put the
nori sheet around the radish i bought
this like fish bone tongue thing remover
so long ago and i was like i'm gonna use
this one day this is my first time using
it but look i was right still using it
needed it oh my gosh i think we got it
he's so cute i'm obsessed with him look
how ready he is to grow up and become an
imposter i'm gonna put him in the fridge
and let's get to working on the yellow
guy oh my god i can't stop looking at
him look it's me and my new best friend
[Music]
now it's time to make our yellow boy
this is my color i am always yellow when
playing among us and whenever someone
steals my color i get very upset about
it i have some rice here i took the
orange guy back out just to scale them
correctly i'm pressing the rice to the
left and to the right so it looks like
there's real shapes for legs that looks
pretty good now we need to make his
little backpack i'm not going to make it
super big because i don't want it to
fall over the yellow soy wrapper is only
going to cover this front part and we'll
stick a piece of nori on the back to
stick it to
the main body i'm just going to cut
around it again extra just in case i
actually can't believe i found the
yellow soy wrappers i take back my
sarcasm earlier when i said that'll be
accessible because i didn't think it'd
be accessible i'm gonna cut these
corners
this is like craft time i love it i'm
gonna fold down the corners this is like
a wrapping a gift let me cut the excess
off i think that's a good backpack solid
backpack flip this over let's add a
little piece of nori so now we're going
to put this nori sheet here so we're
going to add the backpack to his little
back side right here oh my god it's
already so cute
now
we have these sheets wrapping it around
its legs again
apply pressure apply pressure i want to
be able to seamlessly fold that
downwards so let's just cut here and i
want to get that crease in so i'll press
it down and cut same thing with this
side nice nice nice press that down as
well all right i think that's good it's
so cute you guys look his little
backpack business in the front party in
the back all right let's put him aside
we are going to make the bone i think
this would be enough rice for the bone
right does that look like a bone or does
this just look like a y
it's so cute okay now we can make the
gut so we're gonna pull our spicy tuna
now i have the tuna here we're not going
to need too much so i'm just going to
chop it up
i got some sriracha they don't add this
in the video but i just want to make it
a little more red all right final
touches on this yellow friend all right
let's take some spicy tuna i'm trying
not to touch the top of the bone i don't
want it to go colored how is that
looking oh my god so cute if you're not
having fun doing this oh my goodness
this is so fun this is actually me my
character in the game i'm always yellow
and i'm always the first one to die i
don't know why i'm just like a magnet
for being killed first i don't know if
you guys are ready for this cuteness
overload or maybe i'm not
they're so cute
i think it does look like the among us
characters and i do think it looks close
to what wave mount dora did how can i
eat them they are my friends now
[Music]
i think we're finally done i think we
nailed it down pretty well but i'm going
to bring my boyfriend in and he will be
the final judge bae you're coming to see
three two one open whoa oh my god
hey you did a really good job yay
are they cute yeah very cute not this at
all
no orange is always such i know he looks
pretty fine to me he probably reported
the body no he definitely killed yellow
he killed me i'm always supposed to die
and i'm yellow in the game
do you think they look like the among us
characters yeah and they also look
really really good okay yeah that's
elevated okay let's try this oh my god
i'm so sorry i don't know how this ends
it's not good
good
yeah
okay i wanna buy it
[Music]
it's missing one thing though don't say
wasabi wasabi no
i'm missing with something no it's not
i'm just gonna use hands
[Music]
the flavor is totally different i added
sriracha to the tuna
all right guys i would say that was a
success and i think george gave me a
stamp of approval as well i love sushi i
love among us i think it really helps me
get through this pandemic and uh brings
me closer to all my close friends if you
guys end up making these for yourselves
make sure to snap a picture and tag me
on instagram because i want to see but
until then i'll see you guys next time
oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
you